[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue nos
interactions numéro 76 consacrée au
proche orient vers un regain de
violences après le plan américain c'est
la question que nous posons aujourd'hui
à nos trois invités annick s'isole
bonjour vous êtes spécialiste de
politique étrangère américaine
enseignante à paris iii samy cohen est
avec nous bonjour directeur de recherche
émérite au ceri de sciences po et puis
nous sommes également en direct avec
thierry oberlé le correspondant du
figaro à jérusalem bonjour thierry
bonjour à tous et donc ce plan a été
annoncé mardi à la maison blanche le fab
et donc plan de paix concocté par les
états unis qui réjouit les israéliens
mais catégoriquement refusées par les
palestiniens et un plan annoncé comme
gagnant gagnant par le président
américain a écouté tout pis alors amis
internautes poser nouveau question
déposer vos commentaires sur facebook
sur le figaro on est là pour y répondre
d'abord sami kohen essayer de nous
rafraîchir un petit peu la mémoire on va
montrer cette carte qui a été divulgué
par la maison blanche et qui pourraient
montrer ce
le voilà le prochain état palestinien le
prochain état israélien est ce que vous
pouvez nous décrire un peu les
conséquences de ce plan de paix proposé
par les américains sur les frontières
sur les territoires jeter c'est un plan
qui est différent de ce qui avait été
négocié par ehud barak et yasser arafat
notamment d'abord à camp david et
ensuite à tabac c'est un plan qui est
considérablement en recul par rapport à
ce que arafat avait pu obtenir arafat
avait pu obtenir en fait le maintien de
la souveraineté sur la totalité de la
totalité de la cisjordanie et gaza avec
un échange de territoires qu'ils valent
entre 3 et 5% ou israël garderai le blé
bloc des colonies les annexerait en
échange de quoi l'autorité palestinienne
pour obtenir un territoire équivalent
doivent sur le le territoire d'israël la
maintenance qu'il reste ce doux ce sont
donc ces zones qui sont en beige et qui
ressemblera une espèce d'archipels de
territoire reliés par des ponts des
tunnels
oui oui c'est largement 30 pas parler de
continuité territoriale
en fait quand on regarde le plan il n'ya
pas vraiment de continuité territoriale
sauf par les routes qui permettent de
relier une portion de territoire ou un
autre envoi en fait un véritable gruyère
ou avec notamment des portions qui ont
été accordés au sud de la bande de gaza
la zone industrielle la zone
résidentielle et d'agriculture mais au
total je crois que s'il ya c'est un fat
pourrait se retourner dans sa tombe il
le ferait parce que il doit se mordre
les doigts d'avoir refusé le plan de et
qui avait été concocté à l'époque quand
en 2000 2001 et qui lui donnait quand
même un territoire plus important que
l'actuel territoire qui représente à peu
près 70 à 80 % de ce qui avait été
négocié à l'époque
écoutons maintenant la déclaration de
mahmoud abbas le président de l'autorité
palestinienne
après l'annnonce de ce plan bon tir et
le refus de l'autorité palestinienne
n'est pas une surprise est-ce qu'on peut
détailler les points de ce plan qui
évidemment sont inacceptables pour
mahmoud abbas et les palestiniens
oui c'est absolument pas une surprise le
petit d'homme trump avait d'ailleurs
fait une dernière tentative aussi de
convaincre abbas pâte elexon de devenir
et il n'était plus question puisque ce
plan et était par extrêmement
défavorable aux palestiniens le
principal point qui chante les
palestiniens c'est l'annexion de des
colonies de 30% de l'an territoire vous
êtes une condition inacceptable
et puis ensuite il y a le second point
c'est jérusalem jérusalem capitale
l'état palestinien ses bureaux de slam
et les palestiniens et dans le plan qui
est proposé n'est pas question d'une
capitale à jérusalem est mais dans l'est
où se déroulait mais la nuance est de
taille puisque
pour cette capitale serait de l'autre
côté du mur de séparation dans une sorte
de banlieue s'appelle aux abois à
kapitalis à bout dit oui effectivement
on en parlait annick et c'était toute la
différence entre east jerusalem et
eastern jérusalem ce quart en tout cas à
prononcer donald trump avoir d'ailleurs
qui était aux côtés de donald trump ans
dans l' annonce ça en dit long aussi sur
ce plan et sur la difficulté à le voir
comme un plan gagnant gagnant pour les
deux parties là véritablement c'est
toute la polarisation que le président
trump et une partie de son
administration sont en train d'étendre
au moyen-orient qui étaient représentés
dans cette salle c'est à dire qu'on a
les soutiens électoraux électoraliste du
président trump en campagne donc pour le
mois de novembre prochain qui sont des
représentants de la communauté
évangélique dans le même temps on a
trois ambassadeurs de trois pays arabes
qui ne constitue pas en eux-mêmes
l'ensemble de la ligue arabe va falloir
voir la ligue arabe se réunit samedi
quelle va être la position de l'ensemble
mais on a trois ambassadeurs doman de
bahreïn et des émirats arabes unis
on sait la presse américaine a révélé
que les ambassadeurs d'arabie saoudite
de jordanie et l'egypte avaient été
conviés et ont décliné l'invitation
donc d'ores et déjà on a une ligne de
fracture qui est qui montrent toutes une
extrême difficulté pour les pays arabes
à faire bloc derrière une proposition
certes qui surprend presque positivement
en proposant une solution à deux états
avec tous les bémols de l'archipel dont
vous parliez et que commenter monsieur
cohen
mais dans le même temps c'est vrai que
préside empreintes avaient soufflé le
chaud et le froid sur un état je suis
pas opposé à 2 donc on a sept ce
consensus là qui pourraient peut-être
être négocié mais qui dans la réalité
en terrine non seulement la colonisation
mais potentiellement l'annexion la
validation absolument définitive d'une
colonisation qui certes est si ce plan
est acceptée stopper pas simplement
ralenti arrêté pour les quatre ans qui
viennent
oui mais sauf j'ai envie de dire pour
les palestiniens
les dégâts sont déjà faits c'est à dire
que deux voix là on est sur un fait
accompli et on est sûr donc une un
clivage au moyen-orient et pas qu'au
moyen-orient on y reviendra peut-être au
niveau de la politique intérieure
américaine également qui va rendre tout
consensus impossible
d'ores et déjà indépendamment du veto
palestinien bien évidemment sur ce texte
alors quelques réactions déjà manon nous
dit un plan de paix doit se faire par
définition au détriment l avantage des
deux parties en tenant compte bien
évidemment de l'histoire est une
question bettina nous dit sur facebook
tron n'a pas du tout consulter les
palestiniens pourquoi
samy cohen est ce que est ce que c'est
vrai déjà que les l'équipe rapprochée de
donald trump n'a pas négocié avec les
palestiniens
si vous voulez depuis la reconnaissance
par trempe de jérusalem comme capitale
unifiée d'israël
les relations des relations seront
rompues il n'ya plus même des dead
humanitaire qui est apporté aux
palestiniens et donc on voit bien
d'ailleurs sur le contenu de le contenu
est largement favorable à israël
en tous les cas la droite israélienne
c'était très clair a ajouté
les palestiniens ont vraiment subi cette
politique de pression maximale qui est
d'enfants qui depuis l'arrivée aux
niveaux délirants mais ils ont vraiment
subissent à ces derniers mois depuis 18
mois
leur représentation où washington le
bureau va les soutenir a été fermé
l'aide donc via les nations unies a été
complètement l'aide aux réfugiés étaient
complètement arrêtée par les états unis
et l'agencé internationale pour le
développement des états unis qui
soutenaient la bande de gaza qui donnait
des aides pour les écoles pour les
systèmes de santé a vu son budget
pratiquement réduit à zéro donc on a eu
vraiment les la population palestinienne
mise à genoux avant de voir arriver
effectivement une proposition de
reconstruction utopique et pas du tout à
l'invitation des palestiniens d un autre
internaute d'accord avec souvenirs
ce que vous venez de dire parce qu'apple
nous dise ce plan est une paisible
déclaration de guerre et une
officialisation de la loi du plus fort
effectivement avec les
palestiniens qui ont un genou à terre
dans ce bras de fer
un mot quand même avec vous à nyc
pourquoi la politique étrangère
américaine est à ce point favorable à
israël
est ce d'ailleurs une nouveauté depuis
trois ans ou est-ce que trump est
finalement dans une continuité avec ses
prédécesseurs les deux il est dans une
continuité historique depuis 1948 depuis
que le président harry truman démocrates
en l'occurrence reconnaît l'état
d'israël et entraîne la communauté
internationale à la suite des états unis
ce que le président trump essaye de
faire aujourd'hui
sauf qu'il n'est pas dans la suite de la
seconde guerre mondiale il n'est pas le
successeur de franklin roosevelt et la
communauté internationale reste très
timide
attentiste à l'heure actuelle en tout
cas et ça ne ment pas suivi comme ça a
été le cas en 1948 on n'est plus sous le
choc de l'holocauste non plus dans le
même temps il ya une politique très très
moyenne de de soutien sans condition à
israël contre l'iran
c'est à dire que je pense qu'on ne peut
pas comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer vis-à-vis des palestiniens
aujourd'hui sans regarder le bloc
arabo-israélien que les états unis ont
tenté de construire ces trois dernières
années pour isoler l'iran est
potentiellement entrée en guerre contre
l'iran ce soit c'est la même
terminologie qui est utilisé les
palestiniens comme les iraniens sont
traités de terroristes ceux qui donnent
les mettant sur le même plan que hay que
des ch ou qu'al-qaïda ce qui donne au
président trump les pleins pouvoirs au
titre de la législation post 11
septembre pour effectivement déroulée
sans l'accord du congrès sans jamais
demander son avis au congrès ici encore
le congrès n'a pas été consultés avant
que ce plan de 180 une page soit mise en
ligne sur le site de la maison blanche
c'est une captation de l'exécutif
américain face à ou à côté de l'exécutif
israélien en l'occurrence et cette
fameuse carte
thierry nous en parlions hier c'est
peut-être ce qui constitue la nouveauté
de cette annonce américaine c'est que
pour une fois américains et israéliens
se sont mis d'accord sur une carte et
l'ont publié voilà c'est peut-être ce
qu'on retiendra de cette de cette
annonce de mardi oui c'est à dire qu'il
bien sûr il y avait des cartes lors des
précédents
tentative de négociation des accords
d'oslo mais ces cartes n'avaient pas la
même diffusion et la trame de ses tweets
et et ils ont pris une ampleur
considérable 0 il ya un impact
considérable une part sur les
palestiniens qui sont bien rendus l'on
ne leur restait plus grand-chose leur
territoire et d'autre part sur les
pauvres où les colons sur le pq je kiffe
ces cartes comme lui ne prendre que toi
du coup j'en oublierais presque le dans
le même temps le plan prévoit est de
créer un état palestinien
en même temps aussi on a eu peur on a vu
apparaître ce tunnel c'est pas votre
mail tout le monde sait vie
extraordinaire sera encore un peu
suscité bizarre ils veulent faire un
petit mail comme si puisque le hamas
construit on va lui servir
en fait non il passe alors eh bien le
tunnel et ce tunnel il existe aussi sur
les cartes des précédents et de ses
tentatives de négociation est d'accord
question vous est posée en ce concerne
la continuité ou pas de 30 par rapport
aux prêts auprès des ce et à ses
prédécesseurs
hier quand même je rajoute donc de deux
petites précisions
la première c'est que par rapport à la
période clinton et même par rapport à la
période carter qui a négocié café
négocier les le traité de paix entre
l'egypte et israël
il y avait une méthode la méthode
c'était que les deux parties se
mettaient d'accord les états unis et des
soutenait éventuellement faisait
pression là c'est plus le cas là c'est
vraiment une action militaire
unilatérale le président des états unis
décident de territoire qui lui
appartiennent pas qu'ils n'appartiennent
pas à israël et qui vont s'appliquer
maintenant à l'avenir aux palestiniens
ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième c'est qu'il faut aux comparé
par rapport à la période
obama qui en décembre le 23 décembre
902 2016 pardon avait rallié c'est pas
trop ces terrains tracés mon
anniversaire 2016
il avait voté une résolution du conseil
de sécurité qui refusait de reconnaître
les colonies
étant contraire au droit international
il ya quand même deux points sur
lesquels cet appareil
ce plan de paix donc consacre jérusalem
capitale indivisible d'israël alors que
la ville est le troisième lieu saint de
l'islam après la mecque et médine donald
trump a d'ailleurs employé des mots très
forts à l'égard du monde musulman
écoutez nous c'est et pourtant le monde
musulman ses tantes et qu'il n'y en ait
qu'un s'il tentait qu'ils soient unis ne
condamne pas unanimement ce plan de paix
et on observe plutôt un silence gêné sur
la question comment vous expliquer sa
famille toi écoutez la question est
délicate je le sens j'ai quand même
l'impression que il ya une certaine
lassitude
fait beaucoup dans beaucoup de pays du
monde arabe concernant la question
israélo palestinienne qu'elle devenue
pour elle vraiment secondaire et pas du
tout prioritaire comme l'était
auparavant que véritablement la priorité
des priorités c'est l'iran
c'est la menace iranienne c'est comment
la contenir l'affaiblir et pour ça
beaucoup de pays arabes ont besoin des
etats-unis elle-même
on m'a besoins d'israël parce qu israël
est pratiquement le seul pays qui
bombardent des cibles iraniennes
il se situe en syrie et en irak
annick si l on peut parler aussi vous
l'avez évoqué en début d'émission le
long travail de persuasion de certaines
monarchies du golfe par exemple de
l'arabie saoudite depuis trois ans de
l'équipe jared kushner par exemple pour
essayer justement de rallier ces pays à
la cause américaine dans l'optique aussi
de les faire accepter
même si la pilule est difficile à avaler
ce plan de paix américain
l'administration trump quelque part à sa
manière je crois que faut il faut
vraiment qu'on fasse très attention ne
pas se laisser embarquer par le reality
show auquel on a assisté ces dernières
24 heures est en train d administration
est en train de recomposer quelque part
le moyen-orient est en train de 1,2
d'essayer alors en l'occurrence en
continuité finalement avec
l'administration obama d'art créé la
nistration mona rêvait de créer une
espèce d'autant arabe de pouvoir
permettre le retrait des états unis avec
une alliance de défense intérieur c'est
à dire d'essayer de faire que le
dialogue qui était l'apanage de la
politique d'obama permettent de déido
les israël et plus de coopération entre
le monde arabe et israël est
potentiellement l'iran on à la
diabolisation de l'iran sous trump qui
était déjà républicaine soudée obama
sans surprise qui tissent dessus de ce
fait une alliance peut-être contre
nature mais l'alliance de circonstance
de realpolitik on dirait en sciences
politiques de réalisme politique est au
centre de cette alliance il y à israël
pour les raisons militaires aussi et de
renseignements qui évoquait
cohen qui sont nécessaires qui sont
partagés aujourd'hui l'enseignement
israélien est en partie partagé avec
l'arabie saoudite aujourd'hui donc cette
administration trump est en train de
profiter à la fois des moyens qui
existent au moyen-orient qui n'existait
pas il ya dix ou quinze ans de d'une
volonté peut-être de prise en main aussi
un certain nombre de puissances moyennes
orientales aujourd'hui qui sont aussi
des puissances militaires je pense aux
émirats pas simplement al arabi qui sont
des puissances militaires pas simplement
dans leur région et qui sont qui ont
intérêt aujourd'hui comme si le problème
palestinien était un problème du 20e
siècle
mais le reste du moyen-orient est passé
au 21e je pense que ça explique aussi le
fait qu'il y ait moins de soutien
apparent c'est à dire qu' on n'est pas
sévère à une autre dimension ou des pays
du golfe sont aujourd'hui présents en
libye sont présents en dehors de leurs
de la péninsule arabo persique et la
grande menace est effectivement l'iran
donc on a besoin de cette alliance avec
les américains
elle ne peut pas être rompu et si ça se
fait je lui en veux dire une nouvelle
fois sur le dos des palestiniens
c'est un petit peu le choix impossible
mais le choix que la le réalisme
politique du xxième siècle contre un
avec en plus une résurgence possible de
dèche
au milieu de tout ça donc il y à des
périls plus graves malheureusement pour
la population palestinienne ce genre de
notation très timide que l'on observe
alors vous êtes déjà nombreux à
commenter bettina nous pose encore une
question philippe j'y reviens dans un
instant et il y a également bien ou qui
nous dit les pays arabes développer
c'est vraiment dans dans le thème de ce
que l'on vient de
de raconter les pays arabes développer
et riches ont besoin de la recherche de
la production israélienne pour ce qui
concerne les systèmes de sécurité les
technologies de pointe pour les hôpitaux
les ordinateurs les avions comme les
pays occidentaux dont ils n'ont pas ces
serments envie de faire la guerre à
leurs fournisseurs tirer on va
maintenant parler revenir un petit peu
plus quand même en cisjordanie dans la
bande de gaza au proche orient avec vous
on a vu plusieurs rassemblements depuis
mardi à gaza par exemple à bethléem vous
allez en découvrir quelques images
hier soir on a appris qu'une roquette
tirée depuis gaza avait touché israël
alors au proche orient est ce qu'on doit
redouter
avec ce plan de paix américain et son
annonce en tout cas un nouvel accès de
violence on peut le redouter mais pas
d'eau va pas dans l'immédiat pas dans
les prochains temps dans les prochaines
semaines les réactions à l'annoncé du
plan paix de trump pour mme été
extrêmement faible malgré quelques
images spectaculaires de mobilisation
j'étais à ramallah il y avait au maximum
200 manifestants la mobilisation était
un peu plus forte à gaza et mais on sent
qu'il n'y a pas des journées de larache
qui ont été annoncées en fait elles ont
débouché sur pas grand chose
c'est une sorte d'indifférence
d'abattement de la population qui ne
rentrent pas dans un mouvement de
révolte pour l'instant et en même temps
sur le plan plus politique
mahmoud abbas celui d'un discours qui
était assis un contrat soirée qui était
la même sur deux de son impuissance
il a dit jerusalem les barreaux pour les
droits des palestiniens ne sont pas à
vendre mais lorsqu'il s'est agi de de
définir une stratégie pour essayer de
contrer ce plan annoncé qu'il allait
internationale
quel est son sens uni et mobilisé la
communauté internationale mais il a
assez e2 de munitions réagir
il y en a quelques-unes et il
pas les utiliser pour l'instant à ce que
de toute façon si il sera obligé d'en
utiliser des armes légales extrême et il
ne va pas le faire évidemment pas
l'annexion ne sera pas réels au mois
ce plan de paix américain a ressoudé les
palestiniens entre eux et là je parle du
fatah et du hamas
ou est-ce que tout cela va voler en
éclats dans les prochaines semaines il
ya eu effectivement le soir de l'annoncé
du plan
une réunion dans le bureau de de abbas à
ramallah
et pour la première fois tu des factions
étaient présentes
le hamas est même dynamique alors est ce
que ça signifie qu'il y aura franchement
une mutuelle mans on se serre les coudes
et à terme le désaccord profond entre le
hamas qui occupe la bande de gaza le
fatah a en cisjordanie et continue à
être réelle
même si on parle de section qui
pourraient législatives et pourquoi pas
ensuite présidentielle ouais se tenir au
cours du premier semestre
merci elle a quelques questions
d'internautes
nous avons suisse qui nous posent sur
figaro live avec ce plan du siècle peut
être
ils iront une petite ironie ici n'allons
nous pas vers une solution non pas à
deux états mais à un état sami votre
réponse non pas forcément
l etat veut dire qu' il n'y aurait pas
d'état palestinien que l'ensemble la
cisjordanie passeraient sous
souveraineté israélienne et qu'avec un
long run de citoyenneté et les étudiants
à la série twilight et la citoyenneté
s'appliquerait ou pas parce que la
droite la droite dure israélienne nous
souhaite pas qu'elle soit là sûr que la
retape la citoyenneté s'applique aux
palestiniens donc il sera en fête des
citoyens de deuxième zone
et donc on aurait un espace dans lequel
au total les arabes seraient
majoritaires par rapport aux juifs et
donc ce ne serait plus un état
démocratique
un excellent jeu va réagir juste juste
une réflexion sur qu'est ce qu'un état
le plan de 180 pages est en ligne sur le
site de la maison blanche où il est
écrit en toutes lettres que les
palestiniens doivent désarmer et que
leur défense seraient assurés seront
assurés par israël est ce qu'un état
palestinien sans moyens d'autodéfense
contre une menace extérieure est un état
souverain et à partir de là on joue sur
les mots
mais il ne s'agit pas d'un état
palestinien effectivement peut-être
d'une confédération quelque chose mais
d'une possibilité donc d'annexion ou de
mise sous tutelle d'un protectorat je
sais pas comment il faut appeler ça mais
un état qui n'est pas chargée de sa
propre défense n'est pas un état pas
selon la législation internationale en
tout cas mais ça ne pose encore une
question je vous la pose d'ailleurs
thierry les négociations et les
propositions sont-elles complètement
arrêtés ou bien elle y at il encore un
espoir est ce que le dialogue est
définitivement rompu en d'autres termes
syrie il ya très peu d'espoir parce que
je ne vois pas comment comment les
palestiniens pourrait on leur donne
effectivement délai pourra se prononcer
sur ce plan mais c'est pendant cette
période en principe il n'y aura pas de
mise en place de mesures particulières
mais je ne vois pas morts palestiniens
pourraient revenir en arrière et dire
ben finalement on a bien réfléchi en
parcourant m ça me semble totalement
irréaliste dernière partie de cette
émission maintenant pour rappeler que
dans cette annonce d'un plan de paix
américain aux côtés de benyamin
netanyahou il faut aussi lire une
problématique derrière tout cela de
politique intérieure que ce soit
d'ailleurs côté américain où côté israël
commençons avec vous à nyc effectivement
il ya un candidat à sa réélection donald
trump qui en ce moment en plein procès
d' impeachment voilà il faut aussi le
rappeler pour montrer qu'il veut
détourner peut-être l'attention
médiatique sur sur ce procès me weitzman
gagnant gagnant pour lui à tous à tout
point de vue à la fois pour rassembler
sa base électorale
non pas qu'elle l'ait vraiment lâché et
est encore à 40 % de popularité
sa base est bien solide derrière lui une
base électorale qui récupère à la fois
les évangéliques américains plutôt
sioniste et donc sans condition du côté
d'israël et de ce plan à la fois une
partie du lobby juif américain qui le
continue de le suivre et qui accueille
tous les discours que ce soit du
président prend un coup de main et
pompéo son ministre des affaires
étrangères bien volontiers mais
l'ajustement de minus nous dînons train
tu ne fais que flatter son électorat
juif américain en vue de sa réélection
c'est le seul électorat qui ce qui
l'intéressait pas le seul
et quand je dis c'est gagnant gagnant
c'est qu'il permet non seulement donc de
récupérer également les évangéliques et
c'est une très grosse partie de son
électorat mais il salue permet aussi les
premières réactions à la chambre des
représentants du congrès chambre des
représentants qui a une majorité
démocrate montre un clivage au sein du
parti démocrate entre cette ligne
historique depuis 1948 qui soutient
israël et qui ne peut pas s'aliéner
disons le lobby juif américain plus
progressistes qui était représenté par
jay street sous obama
ils peuvent pas s'aliéner cette partie
là de leur électorat en même temps
elizabeth warren candidate à la
présidence et à la présidence pardon et
plus plus radical a absolument récuser
lens
bhl du plan ce qui fait qu'il réussit
dans le même temps à cliver le parti
démocrate sur une question sensible et
qui de toute façon est au coeur de
toutes les élections américaines pour
des raisons et non religieuse en interne
et pour des raisons que bill clinton et
le dernier président qui a touché du
doigt un plan de paix
israélo-palestinien à la toute fin de
son mandat barack obama effectivement
n'arrivant jamais malgré tout la
diplomatie navette vers tel aviv
n'arrivant jamais à véritablement
réamorcer quoi que ce soit les colonies
ayant trop avancé aussi territorialement
pendant son mandat et la séquence est
donc troublant de ressemblance avec la
situation de benyamin nétanyahou qui est
donc formellement mis en examen mardi et
qui est également candidat à sa
réélection dans des élections du 2 mars
qui sont les troisièmes en un an
sami kohen voilà il y a aussi un enjeu
peut-être encore plus fort pour benjamin
netanyahu électorale un enjeu très
important parce que au fond ça lui
permet de détourner l'attention et et de
gêner son principal rival
benny ganz qui pensent qu'ils pensaient
qu'ils pensent toujours faire campagne
sur la question
deux des dossiers de corruption qui lui
sont accrochés en fait les différentes
casseroles et là ça permet en vraiment
en resituant le plan de paix au centre
du débat de détourner l'attention des
électeurs et de dire voilà c'est moi qui
ai apporté ce plan c'est moi qui suis le
principal artisan de cette victoire et
donc je suis le seul à même de faire
appliquer ce plan dans la région
thierry est ce que à jérusalem et il les
sondages ont bougé depuis les annonces
de ce plan de paix ou alors depuis qu'il
a été annoncé puisque
depuis un an à peu près vous me direz si
j'ai tort mais les sondages donnaient à
peu près à touche-touche benyamin
nétanyahou et benny gantz et surtout le
problème derrière c'était la formation
de la coalition pour pouvoir gouverner
donc est ce que les sondages d'opinion
ont changé est ce que ce plan de paix
est à même de permettre à netanyahu tu
forger une alliance plus grande s'il
remporte les élections du 2 mars
ce plan paix conforte l'électorat de
droite qui votent au rheu netanyahu
mais dans le même temps il n'y a pas
pour l'instant de l'est du frémissement
dans les sondages qui gagne deux sièges
mais il n'y a pas eu jusqu'à présent
dans les enquêtes d'opinion publique et
les dépositions faites sont tes fichiers
entre les différents clans il ya d'âge
la troisième fois consécutive de
parvenir à zurich et en même temps le le
plant run était favorable aux colons
les pôles ont satisfait mais centre la
création des palestiens il eu du patron
plutôt et messieurs n'y ait pas de
l'extrême droite ionale ont par ailleurs
à licques à hanau et yahoo lui est
vraiment utile dit c'est un peu mon
pagne version il faut oublier toujours
présente lui-même avait donc très limité
de hockey bien regroupée et le parlement
hq les warrants plus et qu'il adopte
il a donc appelé sa demande qu'il est
toujours dans cette position il ne suis
pas picorer la justice et il n'y a pas
en état d'espoir et là l'espoir
certitude d'obtenir une majorité aux
élections législatives
demain une dernière question encore
sur le figaro.fr et sur facebook c'est
parisse paris ce qui nous pose cette
question et je vous la pose sami kohen
parce qu'elle est intéressante trump a
t'il la légitimité d'offrir les
territoires palestiniens en gouvernement
netanyahu alors la légitimité
vous allez probablement de dire non mais
aujourd'hui on a l'impression
j'aimerais vous poser une autre question
qui peut résister aux états unis dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui militairement qui
peut résister à israël militairement
aujourd'hui au proche orient que quand
même sur la il n'a ni la légitimité ni
la légalité parce qu'il va mais c'est
bien le pouvoir d'imposer sa loi c'est
la loi du plus fort qui l'imposent de
toute façon ils essayent de l'imposer il
n'est pas sûr que le proche orient
en tous les cas cette région ne se
transforme pas en une région où le
conflit va rebondir et deviendra encore
plus violent que ce qu'on a connu dans
les dernières années
donc voila se trompe quand même essaye
d'imposer sa vision qui est celle qui
concorde avec celle de netanyahou il et
il n'est pas sûr qu'ils réussissent mais
il paraît sur un cynisme qui finit par
l'emporter et comme vous le disiez en
début d'émission une certaine lassitude
aussi des alliés des palestiniens qui
vont finir par accepter ce plan écoutez
il peut fut ce qui peut se passer d'eux
sous une tout dépend maintenant des
palestiniens est ce que les palestiniens
vont véritablement se rebeller vont
descendre dans la rue vont retourner
dont un viol envers la violence et
effectuez des attentats si c'est le cas
le cas d'une troisième intifada
alors effectivement le plan de trempe
rien arrangé moi je pense que les
palestiniens quelque part à un moment ou
un autre
vont se réveiller vont se réveiller
quand ils verront que le plan d'annexion
dès que le nid entre en véritablement
aux pratiques parce que le plant
d'annexion des colonies faut bien
préciser une chose
l'annexion était prévu déjà sous barack
et et arafat
mais il s'agissait de 3% de du studio
territoire palestinien maintenant c'est
non seulement toutes les colonies et pas
seulement les blocs de colonies mais
c'est également les avant postes
illégaux
ce sont des centaines d'avant postes
illégaux qui seront annexés à israël et
là c'est un changement considérable
merci beaucoup on est pris par le temps
annexe i zal merci beaucoup d'avoir été
sur notre plateau sami kohen thierry
berlik était en direct avec nous depuis
jérusalem
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
avez été nombreux à nous poser des
questions
et c'était bien agréable d'y répondre on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro d'interaction tas
[Musique]